all right another political news Donald
Trump is bad at shaking hands take a
look
so that cat how's it going hey how's it
going hey what what I'm powerful I'm so
sorry all right
I'm so near to the room oh my god that
compilation right that's the art of the
deal
accomplished with my vice news is way
better than I thought it would be when I
heard that there was video of a Trump
working dudes totally different things
and I thought it was so obviously this
armwrestling match
technique is it is some kinda bout in a
self-help book it also tells you to
drink raw eggs and visualize your penis
growing every morning but I tell you
something that did not work on maple
blooded Hunkin Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau he shut that down shut
down the incoming tugs in one swift
shoulder seeds this afternoon take a
look
this is a guys these are hockey players
you can't throw the balance so used to
being on skates the coaches we had to
shake hands after the game but you
didn't say we had to like it The
Comedians Trump's Trump's alpha boy was
counteracted by Trudeau what's a
Canadian power move Milana affordable
health care for all their citizens Tom
Lennon Hey USA you don't think that we
already have a sleeper cell inside this
guess what
give us one reason and we activate the
Barenaked Ladies oh no oh I can almost
do that now the attacking ignore yes man
I'm not a dinosaur I'm sorry guy but it
can't affordable thing is this one and
that's sad
all right like like Harrison Ford you're
getting frantic just speak it just okay
I'm sorry I'm sorry Kyle Kyle they got a
whole city up there called Regina and
we're not supposed to laugh when they
say
Boy Scout